anteriormente hablamos de que
sorprendentemente los animales fueron
los primeros en colonizar o moverse a la
tierra y eso fue incluso antes que las
plantas pero si los animales fueron
primero que comía esa es una muy buena
pregunta
por eso dedicaré todo este vídeo para
aclarar quién estuvo primero en la
tierra y bueno aquí tenemos una
fotografía de las algas en la costa
entonces estas son las algas y solo para
aclarar a las cianobacterias de las que
ya habíamos hablado anteriormente y que
fueron el primer organismo fotosintético
a veces se les llama algas verdiazules
pero en realidad son bacterias las algas
se consideran eucariotas pero no tienen
la estructura de las plantas modernas y
bueno las algas colonizaron las rocas
costeras hace aproximadamente 1.2 mil
millones de años entonces esto fue hace
1.2
y millones de años je por giga mil
millones de años
entonces si quieren saber qué es lo
primero que llegó a la tierra y que se
parezca un poco a las plantas o animales
si es que consideran a las algas
cercanas a las plantas entonces estas
serían las ganadores y esto fue hace 1.2
mil millones de años pero anteriormente
cuando hablamos de que los animales
colonizaron la tierra primero en
realidad no me refería a animales que
sólo vivían en la tierra sino a animales
que probablemente pasaban la mayor parte
del tiempo en el océano recolectando
comida o algo por el estilo y que
después pasaban a la tierra un poco tal
vez para dejar sus huevos porque si lo
pensamos bien la tierra era un buen
lugar para dejar los huevos ya que en
ese tiempo no había más seres ahí así
que estaban protegidos de los
depredadores y los animales de los que
les hablo pudieron haber sido criaturas
similares a las babosas como esta
personas hablan de criaturas parecidas a
las arañas pero independientemente de
cuáles fueran se encontraban en la costa
y fueron criaturas que pasaron la mayor
parte del tiempo en el océano y algunas
veces estaban en la tierra a esto es a
lo que yo me refería cuando dije que los
animales colonizaron la tierra antes que
las plantas y esto ocurrió hace
aproximadamente 530 millones de años 530
millones de años pero ahora los primeros
organismos que vivieron toda su vida en
la tierra fueron las plantas así que
depende de cómo lo veamos si pensamos en
los seres que pasaban parte de su vida
en la tierra tenemos a los animales pero
los primeros seres que empezaron a vivir
toda su vida en la tierra fueron las
plantas y miren aquí tenemos una planta
que se parece mucho a lo que se cree que
fue la primera planta primitiva aunque
en realidad no tenemos fósiles de estas
plantas pero tenemos los fósiles
sus esporas y esos fósiles demuestran
que estas plantas existieron hace
aproximadamente 475 millones de años 475
millones de años entonces hace 1.2 mil
millones de años teníamos a las algas
hace 530 millones de años tenemos
evidencia de seres que salían del océano
y que tal vez dejaban sus huevos en la
tierra y hace 475 millones de años
tenemos evidencia de lo que llamaríamos
realmente plantas pero como les dije esa
evidencia son los fósiles de sus esporas
y bueno finalmente como evidencia de lo
que podríamos llamar realmente animales
que ya pasaban toda su vida en la tierra
el fósil más antiguo se descubrió en
escocia en el año 2004 y miren este es
el fósil y fue descubierto por un
conductor de autobús llamado mike
mike newman es un conductor de autobús
en escocia y de hecho nombraron a esta
criatura en su nombre se conoce como
nummos newman y newman y proviene de
mike newman este fósil tiene 428
millones de años
428 millones de años y actualmente es el
fósil más antiguo que existe de un
animal completamente terrestre
entonces si pensamos en las plantas
terrestres contra los animales
terrestres es decir seres que ya pasaban
toda su vida en la tierra las plantas
fueron primero pero si pensamos en los
seres que salían del agua y pasaban
parte de su vida en la tierra entonces
probablemente ganan los animales pero si
vemos a las algas como plantas entonces
las plantas ganan así que depende mucho
de cómo lo veamos y bueno este fósil
corresponde a un miriápodos que
significa muchas patas lo escribiré
todo
miriam significa 10.000 y eso es mucho
por eso miriápodos significa muchas
patas o mejor dicho muchos pies tal vez
ya conocen a los 100 pies o a los 1.000
pies esos son miriápodos y los primeros
miriápodos existieron hace 428 millones
de años y tal vez vivieron de las
plantas tal vez otros miriápodos y
babosas y otros animales que existieron
en ese tiempo se veían como esto
entonces espero que esto les dé mayor
claridad no fue que en ese tiempo
existieran perros sentados en la tierra
y no tuviera nada que comer pero sí
depende mucho de como definan a una
planta y a un animal para definir quién
estuvo primero en la tierra y depende
también de si consideran como válido el
que pasarán solo una parte de su vida en
la tierra